the founder of the world's biggest hedge
fund ray dalio is putting his efforts
into what he's calling the planet's most
important asset the ocean inspired by
the legendary ocean explorer and
filmmaker jacques cousteau
to dalio and his son mark founded ocean
x in 2018. its mission was to access
unknown corners of the deep and bring
their work wonders back to an audience
using equipment designed with help from
the film director james cameron
the ocean explorer ship is a floating
laboratory like none other enjoy my
conversation with ray dalio about why
exploring the ocean is better than going
into space
the oceans is this totally unexplored
world i mean think of it 72 percent of
the world's surface is the ocean and
i've been a diver since for a long time
but then it's exciting when you go down
there and you see it and it's going to
another world
so there's so much to be discovered
imagine if all the continents in the
world were never discovered
wouldn't you want to go there it's very
exciting and it's very very important
it's our most important asset why is
this fascinated you more than space
well you're not going to see any aliens
in space if you want to go down and see
life
and see the excitement and the color and
all of that's here if you want to take
care of the planet
you're here and it's much more cost
effective